one of the coolest things is when we
take a diver with a disability and open
water the word freedom comes up over and
over and over again because that's how
they describe their feeling my name is
Jim Elliott founder and president of
dive harbor we help people with
disabilities using zero-gravity and
scuba therapy it's a great equalizer we
take their new normal in some cases and
we help create a paradigm shift so now
the individual with the disability isn't
defined by their disability and they go
into a room and people say you do what
you scuba dive
that's impossible you're in a wheelchair
come on I was on my bicycle and I was
struck by a car and I hurt my T 11
vertebrae and severed my spinal cord I
knew that all of a sudden when I lost
the feeling and the ability to move my
legs that life had changed when I was 23
years old I dove into a pool and I
dislocated my c6 c7 vertebra which led
me to be paralyzed from my neck down
I'm totally dependent from someone else
all the time
okay I'd suffer for neurological pain
and I take medication for that but every
time I get into the water I feel better
I don't feel pain for a couple of days
so I love it
we see immediate pain relief individuals
with everything from MS the spinal cord
injuries and cerebral palsy can become
pain-free if we can get divers deep
enough 266 feet which is three
atmospheres there's an extra output of
serotonin in the human body the
serotonin will help with the pain
management up to three weeks
it just helps their quality of life in
so many different ways you know body
mind and spirit
diving is just amazing because I get out
of this position and I can kind of do
whatever I want get in whatever position
I want but you don't get to do on land
when you're kind of stuck to a chair
being weightless is is one of the best
feelings
I was looking myself standing up and
that was for me
fabulous I loved it I was like oh my god
to get I believe I'm seeing myself
standing up again after imagine so many
years 15 years that I got my accident I
feel like total independent I feel like
freedom liberty out of the powerchair
it's me again